now to another example of someone's
social media past catching up to them in
the present it involves a journalist
just hired for what many could
reasonably consider a dream job in the
newspaper world fox news media analyst
and host of fox's media buzz howard
kurtz tonight on that dream clouded with
some nightmare tweets the latest hire
for the New York Times editorial board
comes with impressive credentials
Harvard Law grad articles in the
Atlantic Washington Post and The Times
magazine but Sarah's young also comes
with a baggage of inflammatory and
racist Twitter posts which unleashed a
fierce backlash on some conservative
websites John tweeted between 2013 and
2015 that white men are grumbling
goblins and BS dumbass blanking white
people marking up the internet with
their opinions like dogs blanking on
fire hydrants oh man it's kind of sick
how much joy I get out of being cruel to
old white men I dare you to get on
Wikipedia and play things white people
can definitely take credit for it's
really hard the time said in a statement
today that her journalism and the fact
that she is a young Asian woman have
made her a subject of frequent online
harassment for a period of time she
responded to that harassment by
imitating the rhetoric of her harassers
she sees now this approach only served
to feed the vitriol she regrets it and
The Times does not condone it in her own
response Jung said the tweets were
intended as satire and she understands
how hurtful they seem out of context she
said that as a woman of color she has
faced torrents of online hate such as if
I saw you I would sock you writing your
lesbian face shut the blank up you dog
eating [ __ ] dredging up offensive tweets
has become a bloodsport in the media in
February the Times editorial board
announced the hiring of tech writer
Quinn Norton and six hours later they
parted company after an uproar over
homophobic slurs and her online
friendship with a white supremacist in
March the Atlantic hired and very
quickly fired national reviews Kevin
Williamson over such controversial
tweets as the law should treat abortion
like any other homicide Williamson said
today that places like The Times should
hold the line again
mass hysteria and the mob mentality of
social media in the Twitter era most
journalists have a past that can be and
often is used against them and if they
joined in the online vitriol the
consequences can be just as ugly Brett
Hali thank you